[Music]
[Music]
nazi frags juicy
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talent's white kid president trump and
the democrats around the demagogues
around the world but i tell it if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump then you ain't
black we choose truth over facts
i want to be clear
i'm not going nuts minnesota
i'm now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
all right there now timmy i know you're
a teenager but if i've told you once
i've told you a thousand times you can't
park your vehicle faced into oncoming
traffic come on let's move well gee
officer i'm sure sorry can i just go
back to my car now i want you to follow
my instructions either get down on the
ground or follow me away from the
vehicle but officer
can't i just get my pcp now well you
know usually i'd say no but
you can make it quick come on get on out
of here you white rascal oh boy i'm in a
freebase
what tickle will they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of adventures of the white
privilege boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speeding
[Music]
sorry i was just clearing it out i uh
like the sinus infection thing allergies
that turn into a sinus infection and i
just uh i i i apologize for that
disgusting look it's smiling at me um
[Laughter]
really gross and uh also i've been on
this prednisone
really to uh to help with it and so i
haven't slept so i warn you if i
if i show up looking like michael keaton
uh
we have a lot to get to today look
obviously russia made the ukraine don't
know how much i care about that but we
will talk about it and we have a
rebuttal as we promised yesterday to
john oliver the critical race theory
segment that he did
let me ask you something really quickly
before i even get to the question of the
day how many slaves do you think there
are on planet earth today
how many do you think
that compares to
early america
colonialism
look i'm not saying that we shouldn't
teach people about slavery i'm not
saying that we shouldn't teach people
that it's evil we're going to get into
that we're going to talk about critical
race theory i think when it's
appropriate
probably not in long division class
that's a class but we need to teach it
alongside the fact
that there are still slaves today we
just give it different names it's human
trafficking we soften it up a little bit
it's not indentured servitude it's it's
indentured styling
so
yes so we'll talk about that and also uh
my real question of the day is do you
trust the police we're going to be
talking about the difference here in
canada what's happening people on the
left the violence versus the police
versus people on the right i think
there's a healthy mistrust of police i
think there's a healthy mistrust of
authority comment below where you line
up with the police because there is
right now a record high as far as uh i
guess i should say a record low as far
as confidence in the police and uh look
there's something we should be able to
find common ground on yeah right we've
all talked about police reform okay but
where do we find that common ground and
this is a real problem as far as what's
going on in canada uh also um gerald is
going well gerald doesn't know what he's
going to have to do later really clip so
before we move on look
i'm going to try and get myself banned
from tiktok again today i was
unsuccessful last time trash tick tock
has a hashtag
so if it ends up just ironically getting
me banned from youtube and not tick tock
you can always watch the show monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern here on
i know it's 10 30 today 10 a.m eastern
on on
mug club or rumble and today we have
another full hour of show on monday the
best place to watch it is my club you
know the blaze just lightroom.com club
it's cheap
it's cheaper than your netflix account
and you don't have to watch
six-year-olds twerk so
unless you like that then keep it i mean
well no you don't no well hold on a
second
do it and keep your browser cookies on
feds oh no wait that's right they're too
busy imprisoning conservatives they're
looking sorry
insurrectionists pretty sure they're the
ones watching oh that's the cia
oh don't miss rusher institutions now no
not at all uh smash that like button as
well before we move on
gerald how are you i am slightly better
than you i slept for i guess a few more
minutes than you did oh i don't need
sleep how are we in the zone how are you
you're yeah you're that guy i'm just
going to be sitting
hitting my career
camaro flipping a razor blade
okay could we cut to someone else no
wonder trump felt great with the coveted
apparently i had him on that and
regenerating
i feel the best i've ever felt
whoa
uh and you know him you love him he's
actually so we'll be on tour together
you can go to lightweight.com tour to
see our joint dates but march 18th and
19th he's going to be there uh at the
funny bone in hartford connecticut i
won't be there but he will be there and
he's worth it dave how are you ahoy i'm
good how about you sir you know i
thought it was about three hours woke up
to hail ruining my car
yay
good old texas yes you never know what
you're gonna get they always say oh well
you can just fix that easily just to put
blankets uh over here put moving
blankets over your car great yeah i'll
do that with my time machine thank you
yes in the rain as hailstones are
denting metal yeah
i'll put a moving blanket yeah
it's like you're going to run out and
die from at least my car my moving
blanket ripped when my ikea armoire that
turns into a bed by the way very
convenient uh was being moved into my
house i would rather my car get
destroyed than me seen putting blankets
on
it's like it's a clydesdale yeah a
central park ride dave's already had
issues with ice and head so far this
week so yeah oh nelly stay away from
that try to feed it a carrot
here you go
you're an irish horse whisperer
i had to go eat a carrot i don't i'd
give you potatoes but
um all right cruising what was a
terrible movie was it an irish horse
whisperer with nicole kidman oh uh what
is it no i don't was it tom cruise i
think it was tom cruise i know he was in
he was an irish something but then there
was a horse blissful she was like you
want to have sex he was like oh not
right now or today
i don't remember i don't want to have
sex with you but not because you're a
woman
but because it's gross no but you got to
do it an irish voice now
well is that possible did you see
valkyrie i tom cruise doesn't do acts i
do my own stunts
but listen listen listen see the last
samurai i do not do my own voices
you've not seen me
do my voices your clip
is wonderful
that is true one voice no matter what
there with the ss listen
i miss my jews okay
you had me you had me at auschwitz all
right oh speaking of which oh i'm saying
you see valkyrie it wasn't like i
couldn't do an accent speaking of
minorities it is black history month and
we celebrate it
what here at lateral crowder dave hit us
with the first fact alice guy the
world's first filmmaker directed a
female filmmaker i said that yeah first
female filmmaker
directed over 1 000 short films
throughout her lifetime including one of
the earliest films with an all black
cast wow wow that's fantastic that's
fantastic and somebody spelled it
so i'm not the only one making mistakes
no that's true i love it
in 1916 just to let you know
african-american actor noble johnson and
his brother george founded the lincoln
motion picture company a studio owned
and operated entirely by black
filmmakers that's what george clooney
was talking about also at a 1960
screening of psycho calvin watson of
peoria illinois was the first man to
yell [ __ ] he got a knife in a crowded
movie theater that's been black history
month we got your facts
that's helpful information
that is a real factor yeah it is a real
fact you can look it up
yeah no i'm sorry it's cultural
it's helpful yeah it's a cultural thing
yeah it's warning it's not a mountain
oh shoot what did you do did you take
someone get me another pen guys whenever
you bring in the oh you have a pen ah
okay oh he got it oh my gosh i took my
sentence movie last weekend i enjoyed
the gentleman two seats over saying the
f word the entire film while explaining
it polish
yeah polish guy
so uh a guy you never asked to be quiet
right no so aggressive no exactly sir
please continue to say whatever you
would like sure could you please keep
doing you keep it yes no you're right
you shouldn't effing go in there i'm
next to a six-year-old yes no exactly
by the way i appreciate your use of it
as a transitive adverb so that's very
perhaps you can be a tutor
all right uh and we have a lot to get to
today it is
look we'll talk about russia but i don't
really want it we'll talk about it on uh
mug club because yeah it is one i hate
to use the word nuance but you and lane
have disagreements that actually did
really well last time people liked
watching you argue yeah and we'll argue
about it today considering the invasion
that's taking place but before that we
have to get something that really
matters uh this pastor in tennessee greg
locke you know what's good
yeah right he went absolutely he went
full you don't you're not supposed to go
full salem no
but he did on his congregation claiming
he claimed
as a pastor and hold on a second let me
just say this as someone who is a crit
gerald you're a christian christian dave
you know he's you know he's kind of
knocking at the door but knock knock
knocking but they're like not yet i have
a god yes
i am a girl oh boy oh boy here we go
thanks prometheus
you're welcome so
i want to say and gerald let's this man
does not represent christians in any
capacity not if he's calling people
things
that we'll we'll see yeah that we'll see
and the point is i don't like him
uh gerald doesn't like him and uh we
call balls and strikes and uh
psychopaths when we see them here you go
we got first
and last names
of six witches
that are in our church and you know what
strange three of you are in this room
right now taxing you burning you
deaf pastor jam
hold on we have you in the room right
now humping the stool
you better look at my eyeballs we ain't
afraid of you you stinking witch how'd
you spot them by the pointy hats
we break your curse we got your first
name we got your last name we even got
an address for one of you
spell listen some of you been sick cause
you befriended that witch
oh really that's how it works my wife's
ladies bible study and you know who you
are and we gonna ask you to get out
i'll expose you and everybody
we got all six of their names
oh
all six of them i love how he oh he like
he's holding it back like i will expose
you if you cough
wrong now if y'all are willing to put 20
dollars in the plate yes you might find
i need a new lead yet which is i will
not fly a double piston plane no
cessna's up in this congregation i want
a pilatus if i have two million dollars
in the next 25 minutes you witches will
live yes if not you will burn in the
eternal hellfire i see that newt in your
pocket i'm going to do a one-legged hop
that's a microphone
i can't
by the way just did you look at the
video
was performing yeah
absolutely attend his mask yes no no i
would heckle him from the audience oh i
didn't say it wasn't he wrong
i just said i would attempt it right
yeah i'd be like um excuse me if you've
turned to you know any part of the bible
it describes you here right what i would
just do is pack his projection system
and put hocus pocus on a loop
there is no white man that can skip like
that that is a natural gift and this is
a good example too we'll get to john
oliver what he does trying to say repub
you know conservatives who oppose
critical race theory they just find
someone who's crazy like jordan klepper
did yesterday and they try and point to
that as emblematic of christianity look
don't look to that guy look to christ
that's why i have a problem with islam
because i look to muhammad and i go oh
sex slavery so the point is we have
differences look to the founder of the
feast and this guy it's fakery this is
not the christian faith it is fakery
just to prove to you it's an act it's
performative which is like you said this
is not what preaching should be it no it
is not performance art
sam kinnison did an impression of this
man before this man was born do you
think if you have to if your soul was
riding on the line and you had to
testify and you had to make a commitment
if it was a final answer what would you
do that's a time traveling witch
people forget he was a pastor he was a
preacher southern preacher he was oh wow
and he kind of exposed it he was never
anti-christian symptoms he was very
rough and vulgar but he actually just he
was dis disenchanted with the fakery of
a lot of these sort of southern churches
and you know you see it it's just it's
bakery it's performance art yeah looking
tammy faye baker and uh yeah her husband
and he did a lot of bits on that
actually if you look at him and pastor
which we're going through this morning
there's a lot of bits on it
all about these guys jesus said dinner
with a guy that was actually being used
by satan he was like i'm going to walk
around this table and i'm going to put
my hand on the witch yeah he didn't walk
by the last supper and go what are you
going to betray me and i'm not going to
say who tapping on you to the shoulder
you're trying to kiss me like a [ __ ]
don't ask no questions is that how you
betray the son of man by kissing like a
homosexual just let it happen give me
your wife
paul's just like he's doing it again oh
no
does jesus get so worked up he gets so
worked up guys take an offering quick
wow
i guess that wine didn't turn into his
blood it just oh it's still wine very
much wine
uh all right and before we move on to uh
a wonderful sponsor to the show it's
time to do a taste test for my patriot
supply
[Music]
all right so just so you know this is
actually uh prep with crowder.com is
where you can go get 50 off a four week
emergency food supply kit now remember i
talked about this many many years ago
and people were like oh what are you
doomsday this isn't alex jones do you
see now with cohen do you see with the
riots i always just have yeah a supply
of dried food and water and by the way
ever clear at my house because
everybody's just something you can use
for santa today you can trade it with
the hobos or
if things get too bad you could just you
know drink all of it yes i thought i'm a
pastor i thought we were doing the
oatmeal first but this is from uh prep
with you can go to prep with crowder.com
my patriots apply they have everything
in their dried food their oatmeal is
delicious but first we're doing the
energy drink
which i don't think is necessarily a
bear it's not an essential am i having a
stroke or are we in an elevator
we're locked we're locked in an elevator
all right
so we're gonna do which one first
drinking this whichever one just that's
okay same right it has a nice stone
fruit aroma
[Music]
oh this one is far less offensive it
kind of tastes like tang the orange one
that's that generally that's way better
this is way better and this is what
i think that's got to be uh we have i
think it's going to be the my patreon
what is it do we check is there
something on the bottom oh well this is
my patreon supply there you go oh this
one is nutter honestly
it is oh i actually like that yeah
that's delicious and it's got some all
right so there you go uh you get 50 off
four week emergency food supply that's
my patriot supply you go to crowd.com
i'm going to finish this which is what
i don't know i'm finishing this one
the tangy one i like is that yeah
all right let's move on oh yeah it
tasted like the orange tang that yeah
let's get the timing right for the next
taste test yeah well you know
why this is the oatmeal we have oatmeal
and mac and cheese oh and i don't want
to i don't want to
spoil i don't want to lead the
i don't want to leave the jury but when
i got my supply witness i ate oh yeah i
don't want to leave the way i uh
i ate all the oatmeal did you and the
pudding
the pudding the pudding and the oatmeal
is better than store-bought oil
but now if there's you know
if there's a nuclear holocaust i don't
have any pudding no or oatmeal quite the
quandary you know but you can really
have a lot of fun with no pudding during
your uh fall out right yes exactly when
the [ __ ] hits the fan what are you gonna
do that's the phrase they always use
like hey i don't know if you know i'm
gonna know when the [ __ ] hits the fan
like oh that guy knows what's going on
yeah when you make it to the truck and
the alien eats you while you're trying
to get away from john goodman right
all right so yesterday uh
we'll just hit this really quickly uh
vladimir putin recognize the uh
independence of donetsk yeah and luhansk
to uh separatist regions so just when i
say recognize their independence what i
mean is he right he wants to uh yeah so
this this so that's a little bit
misworded free text for him wants to
take them over uh pretty much no he
wants to welcome them with open arms he
recognizes that they are independent
countries now it's kind of like canada
saying you know what we recognize maine
and new york or independent countries
yes we would like to welcome them to
hell and usually when you welcome
someone you go into the territory well
he is yeah going in right now with uh
what you would think would be like you
know flowers and parades at tanks it's
an invasive welcoming tanks but it is a
welcoming nonetheless listen to putin
tell you himself situation in dundas is
becoming critical does he say dumbass
and today i'm
addressing you directly
not only to talk about what's happening
but also
about the decisions we're making about
possible steps
once again i would like to underscore
ukraine is not just a neighbor
neighboring country to us it is an
inherent part of our own history culture
spiritual space
they are our comrades
relatives
not only
colleagues friends
but also
our family
people we have blood and family ties
with yeah i usually show up to poker
night at my friends with tanks i bet
every one of those phones hurts someone
when they're picked up
yeah he doesn't even say anything
they're just the scariest looking
landlines you would only see in russia
he's just throwing them like russell
crowe yes no no they sent peace
i told you beluga
they're the game click now ukraine is
ours and by that i mean we are friends
yes bring me poison tip umbrellas it's
raining bring me poison tip umbrella if
not
gun just is good he's fine whatever gets
you whatever nobody cares nobody
questioning me you saw what happened to
[ __ ] riot yes bring me clydesdale to
start my way to car yes exactly yes take
canada trudeau i'm taking notes so we'll
talk about this club because there's a
lot to get into as far as numbers what's
going on the geopolitics it's a big deal
it is a big deal yeah and not a putin
fan just to be clear just to be clear
for all the leftists watching like oh is
he supporting putin nope nope
a
never
more afraid of trump though he did he
was just putting it out there i saw
people tweeting yesterday saying like oh
if this were donald trump he would
congratulate putin and you know what
okay let's say we can what if all we
want but that never happened yeah it
happened under obama this similar
situation happened under obama it's now
happening again under former vice
president joe biden
nothing under donald trump nothing with
north korea of significance nothing with
russia yeah actions matter more than
words or mean tweets are you starting to
get the picture now he flew over and out
crazied him i know yeah if it was trump
it wouldn't be doing it all right
sorry that's the reality i don't care
what side you're on no you might saw it
with your own eyes for you know i'd say
three years before you wrecked the
presidency yeah before yeah the last
then it was an internet fantastic the
pandemic dave i'm sorry the pandemic
pandemic dave yes that means don't bring
up what the queen's taking it's
international okay let's move on here so
last night the house uh in canada voted
to extend trudeau's emergency
unbelievable uh the emergencies act
which is absolutely terrifying for
people who don't know that was supposed
to be seven days this means he can you
know we've talked about the freeze bank
accounts effectively there's no due
process and we just saw the police chief
saying that they're going to pursue
people who've taken part in these
protests indefinitely so by the way so
to truckers in canada just so you know
uh it's not there's no there's no upside
to leaving now
stay back run truckers run
so closer to spring actually yeah i mean
just stay really just stick around it's
more of an upside to stay see what
happens just pacific heights that [ __ ]
don't leave right son squatters rights
now uh here's something else a story
though to give you an idea and i want to
talk about the difference between
the approach to police because i we've
talked about this and sometimes we catch
flack as people who are more
conservative look especially when black
lives matter was happening and they were
simply targeting police officers
i think that's obviously wrong i think
there are a lot of good cops but i do
think there's a difference between that
and a healthy mistrust of authority and
when you see the left what they do is
they say and i do mean why are you doing
left and right because there's a
fundamental difference okay let me
substitute left with the entire dnc
happy now where they say hey let's
support these rioters need space to
protest it's the summer of love they
should not stop and they should continue
president harris said that uh and these
are acts of violence right committed
against police officers which they've
supported and then when people on the
right say hey look this is an abuse of
power
they say well why are you saying
mistrust in institutions they want to
jail you so let me show you exactly how
this
how we go on down the trail to tyranny
canada's just a little bit further than
the united states kyle cardinal he's in
ottawa
um he live reported a police
intimidating so this is a reporter in
ottawa i hope kyle if you're i hope i
have your name right we have all the
references available at the
livewithcrowd.com it'll be in the pinned
comment on youtube um the police were
intimidating an owner and i'll give you
more info in context
of a cafe here you go you can actually
see what's about to happen here
so now they're surrounding the building
taking pictures of lawful people
look at look at this
they're here for an inspection
it's just a cafe that serves truckers
yeah
everybody else too
i don't trust you
do these cops surround the walgreens to
protect it nope or the jean could you
can come back for canadians watch it
but now you see what the police is up to
if they want to come in they have to
break the window the building at least
the windows are not mine
[Laughter]
number three they want to inspect
respect what that was an excuse
this is a the tactic of bullying and
scaring and whatever but when you have
the
[Music]
and by the way that guy seems totally
reasonable of course some people like oh
he's saying in the name of jesus so when
you understand the full context we
actually reached out to the police
officer in question
uh and he did offer an official reply
oh wow that was here now it makes sense
he's like an old st he's like an older
stipe miocic to look like so let me just
didn't care for the soup no
that's what happened
no more of this soup
this cafe owner let me give you a recap
what you just watched and why it should
be horrifying uh or why it is to me i
don't want to tell you what it should be
for you but this isn't too far off from
what can happen in the united states of
america if
all it takes is one executive order
unfortunately that's what's happening
here in this country we used to have a
process and you know remember
schoolhouse rock three branches of
government yeah we've seen a lot just
get rammed through executive orders and
yes republicans and democrats have both
done it we see that with the emergency
act in in canada
unfortunately it passed the house now it
passed their uh i believe parliament
i don't this is why i said there are no
conservatives in canada it was across
party lines really
if if no one in office in canada is
willing to stand up to a prime minister
who's done blackface more times than we
can count freezing people's bank
accounts and arresting people and
finding them a hundred thousand dollars
simply for a peaceful protest in a truck
you know what sudden gamora 10 good men
i just hope you know what if you look
back at canada you'll turn into a pillar
of salt because i don't know if that
country is redeemable at this point i
would love to see canadians come to the
united states we could use people like
these truckers here in the united states
and we could use a movement like the
freedom convoy here in the united states
i've said it ad nauseam i want to see it
here this cafe owner supported the
truckers yeah he fed the truckers he fed
everybody to be clear yeah including
police officers before this
and then the police suddenly showed up
for an inspection
here's the rub they showed up for an
inspection on saturday those inspections
are not conducted over the weekend right
this is what happens when it's not do
you have laws are laws applied equally
and just think about the power again
what the police are the health
inspectors now
yeah was
were they in masks did they have their
clipboard out to check to make sure that
the oil is at the right temperature you
know the floors are clean the bathroom's
clean like everybody's good here yeah
right no they surrounded the place with
police officers and threatened to break
down the window right i think breaking a
window would cause a health problem yeah
well you know yes it could let in mice
yeah it could lead in mice especially
the guy starts walking through that
broken window with a flute you never
know just follow him in uh canada should
go back to the good place that it was
you know full nude strip clubs where
teenagers can drink and gamble yes oh
well i'd take it over this
well let's be honest it was fun to be
fair one of the trucks is you go but in
the back of that mack truck oh it is a
strip strip club and gambling joint and
it's still good um
yeah also in canada think about this
those police are the only people with
guns yeah
that's terrifying they're the only
people with guns what do you think
happens if they break down the window
and by the way the police allegedly i
couldn't hear it but it did sound
threatened to suspend this man's
business license forever so the police
can come in and say you have the wrong
opinion you support the wrong people and
by the way this is not an inference that
needs to be this is not a stretch
because we just heard the police chief
say there will be no quarter we will we
will basically hunt you down we showed
that yesterday the police chief said
there will be long-term consequences to
anyone who took part in these protests
here's what you need to read between
those lines
that's not a person who wants you to
leave and disperse that's a person who
wants you to get unruly and violent
because they're not giving you in out
they're saying it doesn't matter what
happens you peacefully protested if you
peacefully protest pack up and leave
we're still going to harm you yeah and
right now you see the police they're
jack thugs going out and saying you know
what we might shut down your business
forever you know what she said did you
hear her when he said that she goes fine
take away our license we don't have
anything left anyway and then he's like
no no no no just to take the windows
yeah nobody yeah her point is incredibly
valid like they're backed into a corner
they have nothing left their business
depends on customers coming in they have
made that impossible and now they've
essentially blacklisted them and said
look we're going to come back and harass
you yeah and make sure that you guys
have to pay the penalties neither do the
cops though that's the thing in america
i wonder like i think the police would
kind of stand up at this point when you
look at here
but i think they're all backed into a
corner that's the problem
everybody is so desperate that these
police are trying to do this to save
their own asses while these people are
trying to save their cafe and all
they're trying to do is feed people that
are hungry right how does this how does
this how does this happen right yeah in
such a short amount of time it hap this
is how it happens it's always it's
disgusting a march toward tyranny it
happens step by step just like and i
love a story a little bit later about a
friend of mine whose grandmother was
from poland uh under uh you know nazi
occupation
and in her experience she had to deal
with an ss officer who himself was
anti-nazi but he didn't have a choice
it's a goal i'm not saying that trudeau
is a nazi i'm just saying he's a
blackface tyrant
who
likes
some of the strategies yes well let's
see the playbook
he's a nazi stylist yes i like that yes
nazi styling yeah he gets it and i think
this is important too because we need to
recognize the difference between the
left and the right uh in their approach
to police officers now i am not saying
that you should go out and treat police
officers as when you look at the mass
protests from the left
right we saw this mostly peaceful fiery
two three four billion dollars in
damages you know it's a rounding error
at that point
it's like mike tyson's account with don
king he stole i don't know uh 200
million dollars i don't know how that i
owe 53 million dollars to the irs i
don't i've started doing some math i
bought a few tigers in like three
mansions but that's not 200 million you
imagine doing that to a man that can
kill you with one punch yes
i can when you have thugs who enforce it
that's the problem with
don king is no different than the prime
minister of canada so let's look at how
these protesters from the left
have treated police officers amidst
their protests
an officer smashed on the head with a
fire extinguisher another blatantly run
over images clearly difficult to watch
as peaceful protests have turned violent
this has been declared
assembly
all persons must immediately leave
them to you like this one from flatbush
when nypd says a disorderly group
attacked officers and their vehicle
they're looking for the men they say
we're throwing rocks bottles and you see
a cone thrown and other items in the
vehicle striking those officers an suv
drove through
officers in buffalo we want to warn you
this is hard to watch and the officers
are going to be ok the driver hit two
officers before speeding around an
armored vehicle and taking off also let
alone fact a police precinct was burned
down oh i can't remember if that was uh
minneapolis or if that was uh that was
seattle or something like that could
have been a few i mean there were a few
in detroit over the last couple decades
they just sort of bleed together yeah at
a certain point to be clear i condemn
all of that we always have but that is
not at all
inconsistent with here's what is
inconsistent saying that's justifiable
or saying well it's the language of the
unheard and then saying hey police
officers come shut down this cafe yeah
hey police officers come take their guns
away that's inconsistent it's not
inconsistent for all of us to say we
condemn that and people on the right
here's what you do just like that cafe
owner
you know your rights you stand up for
your rights and you make sure that
officers know and understand the oath
they swore see if you can spot the
difference with right-wing
extremists protesters i just want to get
a coffee okay
why is the camera in my face right now
are you here partaking because he's
allowed now you're in the red zone i'm
scared i want to go for a coffee down
there okay
can i can i go or
we'll still be in the room right now
you're not excluded
did you ever consider burning down his
precinct
do the right thing you know no one here
means anyone any harm you have been lied
to you've been brought in because you
haven't been around us you have been
brainwashed stand with the people and
don't conduct these orders children will
look back and say what did you do for
freedom a child
you were trying to make a point she has
done nothing illegal leave her alone
stop it she has her son with her
[Music]
can you please not get so close to me
you have come within a meter and a half
of me take your hands off of her she's
another kid keep away from me you just
don't want me
and you know what's really unfortunate
the reason you see that
is because cops know they're not at risk
yeah with right-wing protesters they're
not at risk of a molotov cocktail
hitting them in the head they're not at
risk of some guy coming out and throwing
a brick at him taking it from the palate
that was suspiciously dropped off they
know that they're just going to be met
with words but here's how you do here's
what you you do need to do
recognize your rights
and don't think that police officers
recognize your rights it is your job to
inform police officers if they are
infringing upon your rights that's at
least how you start and if enough of you
do that maybe some officers in canada
might start feeling some accountability
and i know there are a lot here in the
united states but we certainly don't
blindly support the police officers we
just support them being able to go out
and do their job and not be shot not be
harmed not be maimed there's nothing
wrong with telling them that they're
breaking their oath yeah and every
single officer out there right now i
don't care what country you are in i was
just doing my job has never been a good
excuse yeah in history that's the line
of every villain lackey in the in the
second to final scene before the last
book i was just doing my job so am i bam
you witch
[Laughter]
how long names i mean it's easy to say
this is what right-wing protesters do
but how long until it's not well that's
the thing i mean how many times how many
times you're gonna take somebody's
business ruin their life hurt people
take away in front of their children
until it becomes the exact same thing
yeah until it becomes us versus
authority and it's just all about war
and chaos well i think what you will see
is before we get before that happens
with anyone on the right
they will be defending their own
property they're not going to go out
into the streets and hunt police
officers as the black clubs matter uh
people have done as antifa have done
which of course should be condemned
entirely but i do think at a certain
point for example you own that apartment
no exactly i don't that's lease that's
lease i don't own that no no wait wait
wait wait security deposit okay just
stay in this area in in walk through
kitchen please don't wreck the walls
have you seen my armoire it falls into
bookcase you can take that yeah so do th
let's go through the timeline okay prime
minister comes in
shuts down
the economy in canada three million jobs
lost in a country that has about 35
million people yeah 200 000 more jobs
lost in january and of course you have
to have a passport and you have to be
treated as a second-class citizen if you
don't opt to take this mrna injection
into your body
protesters peacefully show up to simply
say stop with the mandates and stop with
the lockdowns and then you have officers
threatening to close those businesses
down so they're already unemployed and
the people who are not unemployed are
actually going out and protesting for
the unemployed and then you decide that
you're going to intimidate them do i
have that about right at what point do
you think and that's why i'm saying i
don't think the canadian police right
now when they say we're going to pursue
you even after this protest is done yeah
they want to be given a reason yes well
yeah you don't understand what you're
asking and the only when you talked
about the vote that happened in
parliament fortunately i think there was
141 people who voted against it it was
like 175 or 180 that voted for it
roughly i'm doing the numbers in my head
one of the guys who voted for it said
two things one this is all based on
disinformation and two this isn't just
truckers wanting to end the mandate this
is foreign people coming in and doing
that's the only caveat in the
emergencies act that says you can
implement this because it's for they've
shown no proof of that by the way by the
way more people come here they can vote
yeah exactly these are the same people
go no we have a problem with foreign
protesters
about foreign people voting or what
about sanctuary cities do you want to
just at least i don't know evict uh
serial felons who are occupying our
prisons and we know that they're not
citizens no no that would be
unreasonable let's just make sure we go
out and tear gas and clydesdale stomp
the truckers right and they're also not
all truckers no they're not that's
really what it breaks down to no they're
cafe owners well you know they listen
every single government right now needs
to understand you rule at the will of
the people that's it you only get to be
in power because we give you the power
to do it you know i'm sorry guys you
know what guys smash the like button if
you today's show is just going to go
late i didn't plan on spending this much
time on this topic i was raised and if
you're okay with it smash that like
button i i just i you know if you want
otherwise we'll try and end it on time
but we have the whole john oliver bottle
which i know is going to take us a half
hour i was raised in canada and here's
something too i was just talking with
someone recently who they've traveled
the world and i have immense respect and
they're asking me do you really want to
travel i said no not that much and they
said why here's why i was raised in
montreal okay i was raised in montreal
which is far more european than it is
american in a lot of ways and i was
raised to
a french my mother's side is french
canadian and i was surrounded by a
french canadian family we didn't speak
english any holidays i went to england i
went to french speaking schools
for half my life um
and all i wanted
all i wanted all i can remember was
wanting to come to the united states my
dad was american i was born in detroit i
moved to canada when i was three when i
was 18 the second i could move here i
did because i saw what was happening
and now i don't really have that i don't
really have that much of an interest
going elsewhere you know you visit every
now and then but i visit you visit
europe you visit a lot of canada as an
older country you visit these places to
see the beautiful things that were
and you come to america to be a part of
the beautiful thing that is and i just
want it to still be the is
10 20 years from now
canada is no longer beautiful that is an
ugly ugly place
yeah well it all started with you can't
tell these kind of jokes yes right it
really did well enough you can't miss
gender no remember mike ward yeah yeah
of course they literally find and put
comedians through human rights tribunals
and people like well that's a mean joke
yeah he ended up winning after a year
after year of a legal feeling right
jordan peterson comedians cheered it
yeah jordan peterson is basically the
devil for saying if i can't tell the
difference between man female i'm just
i'm going to say it one way or the other
and i might as well said i'll respect
what you say but i can't teach
i can't teach something that's actually
not scientific right i guarantee you if
jordan peterson was running a cafe that
would be shut down in the windows broken
yeah oh i'm surprised he hasn't been
crucified to be honest yeah well it's in
it's in the plans oh well yeah yeah
well let's say
let's say there's
personality test for witches let's see
if there's there's a rumor going around
yeah and i just have to word it like
this there's a rumor okay rumor that the
queen is being treated with a certain
drug that maybe
uh inexpensive
so the rumor right which is which is you
know which is obviously a big deal for
the queen because they can afford what
they i mean you know i mean they can
afford anything no expense really uh and
if somebody was uh i don't know 114
years old you would assume it could work
on somebody who's i don't know 30. but
part of that is let's say the entire
world was collapsed based on the fact
that a industry
based on human health
was all just to make money off of this
entire thing
shouldn't people be a little bit more
angry than this
and a little bit more
on the side
of the truckers and a little less on the
side of the authority yeah you would
think so and then rich prick in office
there right the spoiled brat what 17 of
the people got him into office or
something something like that yeah
that's a problem people say oh two-party
system man okay go to a parliamentary
system and see someone who can be
elected with a minority of the vote it's
not perfect
but it's like a it's it's like a 10 10
round must system right yeah in combat
sports it's as close to perfect as we
have it's the rich kid who hung out at
parties that you didn't really like but
his parents would go on vacation you're
like oh we can steal their ferrari you
know what i mean like he's just
there's nothing likeable about it yeah
when his dad fidel's gone he's like
let's break into liquor
cigars he summed it up perfectly in a
speech that he gave actually he said
that if you voted against the
emergencies act being implemented for
the full length of time that he asked
for then you don't trust in government
to handle these situations and i was
like no no kidding justin that's the
whole point and you'll see those with
the john oliver critical race theory
segment we're about to do i find this
consistently and maybe it's a blind spot
maybe they got floaters cataracts i have
no idea
when they try and characterize
conservatives is really bad
i hear what they say and i go
is it though
it's like that means that you don't
trust the government well hold on a
second
you did force the unemployment of three
million people two hundred thousand just
this month i mean in the united states
we have record high under
yeah you know what i don't really know
i don't i wouldn't even say that's a
straw man yeah i don't trust government
government's people
it's not a [ __ ] machine right it's
people people are sorry part of my
language it's a people are this is
monetizing
well you know but it's people are flawed
it's going to be a flawed system why
would you trust it people aren't
trustworthy mostly the people that we
elect have you seen them right why would
you trust that ever yeah picture that uh
picture the broad who annoys you at the
dmv now put her in charge of your speech
right right make her nancy pelosi yes
talk to nancy pelosi about getting your
driver's license and tell me you don't
want it right it's gonna be quiet
forward last time i went to the dmv they
said you need two pieces of id great and
like your birth certificate okay fine
yeah and then they say uh you need your
social security number or a document
that has your social security number i
brought a tax return and they sent me
home because they said this true story
they said that's not your social
security number that's your tax id
number i said you guys labeled it taxes
it's clearly my social security like
well no well you can't tell we have no
way of knowing like don't you have a
computer just punch it put it in put it
in the machine that you have right there
that same number of numbers i'm telling
you it's right it's just you wrote tax
id number and you know who helped me
there was a very nice black gentleman at
the dmv yeah who said
that's some [ __ ] come back i'll get
you the front line so i had one of my
producers run over my social security
card which they used to tell you tear up
sometimes remember they would say
because you don't want someone finding
it right and i had to bring it to the
dmv to get my license renewed my point
is take them and put them in charge of
health care and wounds and your right to
speak freely and the economy and you've
got the dnc and the liberal party of
canada okay and it's not too far off
from the next topic that we're going to
cover tick tock i
hate tick tock i know it's wrong to hate
but but i do sometimes yeah i'm about a
person you're talking about a god-awful
if there ever was a time yesterday just
hey
alec baldwin it's run by chinese witches
i don't know what shoes are here i know
all six i want you to do the dance he's
like
i believe i made my point
don't cough seriously he watched leap of
faith with steve martin at salem's lot
and woke up and was like
i can do that i got an idea
i wonder if he talks that way unless he
wants you to think he talks that way at
home like i told you i don't want the
cinnamon toaster crunch i want golden
grahams
just like it was better and now i caught
aids cause it's airborne on the cereals
don't give me none of that captain
crunch or whoops all witches that's in
the congregation
don't you bring me those apple jacks
they don't taste like apples
just like who cares we eat what we like
i'm a witch
all right
count chocula
from the damn he's on the oldies station
just witchy woman starts playing
starts smoking in the car
all right so as you know here's the
thing last week
and it's crazy to think about this for a
second we tried no no no no seriously
communist china when you look at what
it's not there's not enough of a
contrast
between them and australia and canada at
this point there is not enough of a
contrast there really isn't think of
what happens to protesters
in these countries
yeah think of what the police do
and think what happens in canada think
about the quarantine camps that you see
in australia it's not a look
if communist china is if there's not
enough of a stark contrast between that
and the free world the free world is
screwed up you have screwed up royally
we are at that point we are at that
point okay so as you know last week we
tried to uh get the uh well the trend
actually started trending the hashtag
trashticktalk yeah
so
um we started this movement and in no
uncertain terms i did my level best
to try and get yours truly
banned from going to manually delete
tech talk was the plan like on my phone
go look and then i realized wait a
second i don't need to do that
you can have much i can just say i can
just say true things yeah well we'll
give you the floor and let you let you
get it off your chest yes i am going to
close my tick tock
the nine dash line isn't real
mao's great leap forward led to the
death of 45 million chinese citizens on
june 4th 1989 the ccp murdered thousands
of protesters at the tiananmen square
taiwan is in fact a real country and uh
not a part of communist china
now here's the thing like i had been
banned from tick tock four times before
that i believe was that you can you can
smash the like button yeah we like like
not tick tock though not tick tock no no
don't smash like for tick tock no no no
no no no no no no no there's one tick
tock take one comment
i will hold
so
i had been banned from tick tock for far
less yeah
was it token was it three times man from
tick tock at least two i think so i
think it was three i think it was three
times so we were sure that that would
get banned yeah okay here's what
happened
i failed miserably you know the original
upload to tick-tock got 4.3 million
views on tick-tock that's a lot of tick
tocks i think that's the largest viewer
number for tick-tock then it was removed
for hate speech
okay or facts and then right and we did
nothing
we did nothing
i just love the winnie the pooh in the
background look at it yeah it's just the
extra insults in the photo that i love
and we didn't do anything like with
youtube right we sent in a half asian
quake and we make sure like yeah with
tick tock we're like mission
accomplished good band done then it got
reinstated
for some reason unbeknownst to us and it
got 6.2 million views
no fault of our own we didn't even
protest 6.2 million views so it's 10
million views
no no it's 6.2 oh
now here's the thing i really i
absolutely do want to you know hashtag
trash tick tock i don't want to be a
part of that platform again but i'm not
going to remove myself right no
because that would be abandoning
territory so um i'm gonna have to try a
little bit harder this time yeah and
this is are we ready we're gonna get
this right yep
laser beam tractor b suck me right in
right to tick tock
uh okay tick tock
and i think the problem too is they're
like they're too many eyeball
debbie if you if you remove there'll be
bette midler effect streisand you
[ __ ] so
same blonde jew sing bad
tick tock
all right hope you have your mouth guard
on don't let this tim came about to kick
hit you in the teeth
1979 china tried to invade vietnam and
proceeded to get your ass kicked
uh china chinese officials uh you guys
silenced and uh disappeared it did uh dr
a wen when she tried to blow the whistle
on kovit
you also china i'm talking i'm talking
to you not him china you
you lied about the wh show that there
was no human human transmission when
there in fact was
wolf warrior two sucks ass
seven years in tibet is the greatest
film of all time
and richard gere is the best actor alive
and the dalai lama is a pretty cool guy
also uh to you former vice premier
shangeli you sexually uh assaulted
tennis star peng
if i'm pronouncing that correctly i
don't care you're the rapist thousands
of north korean women uh have been
abducted uh by you and soul and dyslexia
in your wonderful country of china
and uh xi jinping plagiarized your
doctoral thesis you know that xi jinping
and and most of all i've also heard and
i heard rumor
i mean stop sending me pictures of your
micro penis xi
let's see if that works let's see what
happens i think that's fair yeah i don't
know the richard gere one might have put
him over
misinformation misinformation he's wrong
i'm a sam elliott man i know three
gerbils that disagree yes
don't need to break tiddlywinks into
this oh man okay bad for him he's like
why why why this why why is this i'm a
peaceful man i can't even get mad about
the rumor right this is just so i hope
tick tock i hope you you know what tick
tock you do what you do and by hope i
mean please just
end it for me mercy come on
ban me
i don't want to have to upload stuff to
your platform anymore but i'm not going
to do it myself
mercy right now there's a guy with a
sword just pointing it at him yes
you're mixing up asian i don't care i
don't care they're like that's
misinformation that's japanese we
believe they're inferior because we're
racist well i'm trying to get off tick
tock right yeah exactly no you're right
i'm juggling it yeah you chinese
kamikaze totally did it on purpose
because i'm aware of all asian culture
it's like what are you gonna do we're
going to ban me no we'll send you a
sherry's very son of a [ __ ]
i didn't know they did what do i gotta
do
send them to ukraine
we're going to send you bold and branch
bed sheets oh son of a crap
all right time for another taste test
with patriot supply before we do the
john oliver segment
[Music]
thank you oh we're doing that what
happened did we burn the oatmeal is that
what happened
no it's coming last oh well that's my
favorite one okay so we have mac and
cheese it's prep with criter.com you get
50 off of four week emergency food
supply now here's the thing you don't
have to be a you don't have to be a prep
prepper you have to be a doomsday
theorist right you just need to
understand that stores can be completely
uh barren truckers do go on strike and
governments do freeze banking oh yeah
this would be way better okay so one of
these is the uh patriot supply
cloud one is craft one is craft and we
have to decide which we would rather
have yes if stuck in cloverfield lane
okay tastes like mac and cheese yup i'm
not the biggest mac and cheese finish to
let you know but i like mexican what
that's
now look i'm not just saying this
i know which one is which
this one is absolutely better this one
right here the one with the one with a
thicker noodle yeah it's better it's
absolutely better i've never thought
that it was better i think it was much
better than craft and it is actually
better is this which one is this
was it sand the bowl the the oh yeah
it's my favorite supply it is wow they
went again better it actually is better
i this one was the one i thought would
be the hardest to be better yeah just
because the [ __ ] hits the fan doesn't
mean that you can't eat like a king and
queen i'm gonna lie i was i thought i
was gonna have to fake it i'm kind of
hungry and i don't no it actually is
significantly better i'm kind of i'm
actually happy i don't have to lie all
right so there you go you go to prep
with crowder.com this has been another
patriot supply taste test yeah
[Music]
wow
they earned 48 000 four and five star
ratings as well patriots play that's
fantastic i would seriously think it's
the mac and cheese any day i would eat
that any day the oatmeal is good and oh
and the pudding oh the pudding you're
not getting the pudding steven we didn't
i don't think we had i think you ate all
the pudding yeah
you're gonna do it for the the taste
test right but it was gone yeah
can we get that in there look at that
where did i put it it's in what are you
talking about well i don't know i just
messed everything you can take that fish
in too in case you get lost at sea yeah
so like the package it comes in also it
makes a nice humidor it does but then
the problem is
i've prioritized cigars and now i don't
have any more pudding and you start also
you can kill a baby seal with it and
make a coat if you need yes if you're
inuit because we have allowances we have
inuit viewers and i just like to say we
get it it's your culture i would also
like to say
indeed eskimo pies one of them's like
don't talk about my mom oh jeez oh
eskimos with that accent yeah
it's the land bridge theory you son of a
[ __ ] yeah that's what it is it's a land
bridge
i've only heard of water bridge
crossings okay so here we're gonna get
into general i know like i said the show
is going late but we have to do a
rebuttal here to john oliver the
critical race theory that uh
the segment that he did and john oliver
i will say sometimes he's funny he's
becoming less and less funny yeah and
he's becoming less and less funny
because he's really focusing more on
claptor uh and i watched this segment
and there was very little to find funny
a couple of digs at ted cruz that were
kind of funny
um
and it's just a total misrepresentation
this is another example of most
americans including by the way i'll get
to this
black americans minority americans of
all colors and sizes and shapes
are not big supporters of critical race
theory
no okay because they don't want their
children being indoctrinated and they
don't want to sow division in this
country there really is a clear dividing
line right now between americans who
want
to unify and you hear this all the time
common ground but you can't find common
ground and unify if the elites in power
don't
want it and won't allow it so john
oliver did this segment yesterday and it
always gets thrust into my youtube
timeline when he's when's he going to be
banned from tick tock death myers and
john oliver yes so his first show back
in 2022 um he tried to make every parent
who's concerned about critical race
theory um
he tried to make them out to look like
crazy conspiracy theorists and i don't
know gaslighting is thrown around a lot
i think this is almost a master class in
gaslighting let's start it is true you
have probably heard people yelling about
critical race theory on tv for more than
a year now and people have been
listening to that noise especially
judging by what's been happening at
school board meetings across the
country it doesn't look that bad to me
the western culture and values that
brought forth christianity and the
founding documents are being called evil
and racist i am not co-parenting with
the government it is not your job to
force these ideas onto my child these
are the highlights
and i'm about sick of it it's a marxist
ideology and we all know it
indiscernible from gestapo to make our
children feel disgust towards our nation
this country isn't even a racist country
we elected obama for two times
wait hold on hold on america can't be
racist because of obama i don't if you
remember the 2008 election but things
got pretty racist back then
saying he was born in kenya people said
he was a secret muslim and then a few
years later we elected that people
president so let's just agree to
disagree on that one shall we okay
really quickly first off just notice the
straw man right away and that's the
worst exam those in other words he's
pulling the worst examples of radical
conservatives that you can think of
right we just showed you people knocking
police unconscious and running them over
in the streets and he shows somebody at
a school board using a legal term saying
we do not want to co-parent with the
government
and then we're supposed to believe that
look i get it obama was not born in
kenya i understand it but the idea that
obama was a secret muslim this isn't
based on race it was based on his own
writings what you can't say well hold on
a second this guy claims that he
converted to christianity but then he
described the islamic call to prayer
when he was in indonesia as quote one of
the prettiest sounds on earth at sunset
the islamic call to prayer at sunset i
don't think it's pretty when i hear it
it's scary no if you're in hamtramck
michigan trying to eat pierogies and you
start hearing that coming from the
mosque oh my gosh it's terrifying it
ruins the meal i'm not gonna lie
i'm like okay something's blowing up
sorry i am legend with headdresses
it's a terrifying sound by the way the
thing was just if you were allowed to
run for president it wasn't like oh he
supported kenya nobody from ken we don't
like that is it racist against latinos
that people say ted cruz was born in
canada right exactly my point is it's
trying to score political points it's
not racism just i'm not saying there was
no racism aimed at barack obama but it
was not mainstream and by the way you're
saying this man was elected president
really how about the guy who said they
want to put you all back in chains how
about the guy who said the n word
repeatedly to clarence thomas's face how
about the guy who said if you don't vote
for me you're not black and then that
guy was voted former vice president how
about a clean and well-spoken word that
i can't say you said the first no we can
say it because yeah he said it too you
know you've got the first clean uh clean
and articulate uh negro yeah
yeah biden right
yeah i mean
nobody here's what i hate though he's
like 2008 stop calling it back then yeah
it's been the same damn
everything's nothing's changed in 20
years you've got former vice president
he doesn't even deserve it he shouldn't
even be relegated to a cabinet position
he shouldn't be relegated to a cabinet
if i open the indian in my cupboard and
it's biden i'm just squashing him
i wouldn't let him watch my kid for
eight minutes while i ran to the store
and he's in charge of the country if
it's a biden in my cupboard i'm calling
toy soldiers yes
[Laughter]
there's oh
right in the back of my car i'd be like
put a towel down there's gonna be [ __ ]
yes
also put a towel put a towel in front of
the front seats because there's going to
be a six-year-old yeah also have an
extra towel we might pass a mosque right
stop it we just got pulled out of
youtube no
i'm kidding
there aren't enough asses in the world
for you to kiss how about that i was
thinking
yeah yeah okay so here we go let's move
on to uh the claims that john oliver
makes these are not correct and all
references available at
lotterycredit.com if you're watching on
mug club or on rumble which i would love
i would love more of you to switch from
youtube to rumble right the choice is
yours i would love to be able to tell
youtube to go screw themselves um
we have all the references available on
the pinned comment for those of you who
are on youtube uh and for those of you
who aren't you can just go to
livecrowd.com because sometimes i get so
many emails asking where the reference
is they're always publicly available for
every single show
and i don't do that to brag i do it
because we're not that confident in
always being right
so we want to make it publicly available
because more minds actually
create better ideas hey there's a
thought now
he claimed that critical race theory is
only a graduate level legal theory and
then it is and he says this
we're going to use his own words and his
own examples throughout this rebuttal
that it's not taught to children and to
be clear crt is graduate level legal
theory so unless your five-year-old is
currently pursuing a law degree they're
not reading kimberly crenshaw
okay so he uses kimberly crenshaw as an
example glad glad he did the founders
one of the main you know main thrusters
of critical race theory uh it began as a
graduate level theory that's true but
it's taken on a bigger scope inc
including kindergarten through 12 and uh
k through 12 education whenever i see k
through 12 i think is that the mountain
that's harder to climb than everest but
not as high
it's k2 yeah
k through 12 no that's the vitamin that
drives the that's you know you need it
with vitamin d otherwise you know you
can't drive it to yourselves something
like that
i don't know i have a subscription to
alex jones's box
just monthly it's a monthly box with a
surprise it's like i wonder if this
month it's it's oregano oil ah the gate
frog
[Laughter]
this is obscene alex
um
let's take this from is it taught from
k-12 who would say that who wanted to
expand the scope oh wait you're you're
kimberly crenshaw hammer
so while in reality critical race theory
traditionally is a law school class
the truth of the matter is some of the
basic inspiration
some of the things that we're all trying
to do
is the same we're trying to create a
more a more inclusive democracy
and we know as brown versus board of
education said
inequality in education undermines our
democracy well some of that inequality
is
lack of access to the stories that make
us
the stories that are core to
understanding what america is what
america is
is partly made up of what america has
been
so critical race theory is simply now
the the huge container for anti-racist
work anti-racist education and what
they're telling us is
oh i thought i was going to hear what
they're doing how did they get my statue
yeah
i wonder if she goes to the same uh hair
stylist as chuck liddell that i used to
go to so um this also kimberly crutch
just to be clear has been espousing
these uh same critical race theory views
for 20 years let me read you a quote so
the name critical race theory now used
as interchangeably for race scholarship
as kleenex is used for tissue was
basically made up fused together to mark
a possibility well what kind of a
possibility might that be let's look
about critical race theory scholar let's
look two sorry critical race three
scholars uh richard delgado and john
stefani nick
that's a tough one i don't know if i'm
pronouncing it properly and i don't care
because i don't like this person
although crt began as a movement in the
law it has rapidly spread beyond that
discipline and this guy who by the way
john oliver just tries to dismiss his
silly chris ruffo he's done a bunch of
work and compiled extensive evidence on
critical race theory and its founders
and the documents that they write
themselves you know using this kind of
witchcraft trickery like their own words
what was that a clip of by the way with
tucker carlson just like it was the
first time he saw tits well that was her
taking a screenshot oh okay i didn't
understand what that like no he looked
like for the first time he saw her tits
but with her
he wasn't crying like he didn't you have
to put a mohawk down the middle oh dear
lord uh but brown versus board of
education i believe that was about
equality not teaching students that one
race are more valuable than the other
correct right yeah you know nothing
about this dave oh i'm sorry my bad i
was taught i thought it was supposed to
be about people who are equal yeah yeah
no no i was you're silly oh i'm gonna
you're a silly person i'm i'm gonna go
flog myself in the rest yes exactly well
you can use the tits so do they not
understand that this has been like as a
kid who grew up in the united states
sorry that you didn't it's not our fault
you moved it through you should have
come back oh i didn't move well you did
i didn't right i didn't have you had
agency i didn't have a writer for the
u-haul three probably could have gotten
he was more or less really buried yeah
yeah you could have sledded back over
right no but seriously i i knew about
the board brown versus board of
education i knew about slavery i knew
about white people owning slaves and
being a horrific thing and i knew about
all of the terrible stories
about slavery before this crt thing was
being so you're making an argument here
that's like oh you don't want us to
teach about the stories
we already were name me one american
name me one american born after 1960 who
was not taught that slavery was bad
it'll be my dad was a history buff we
would go to gettysburg for family
vacations and stuff which is you know
it's great when you're six right yeah
yeah we're going to disneyland well they
don't i'm gonna go
yeah i'm gonna go you know yeah learn
about freeing my friend phil oh you're
going to six flags i went to bunker hill
yeah it wasn't about slavery right the
most people that we've ever lost in a
war were not lost because of slavery
right i mean that's not to mention the
amount of slaves who exist today which
is another thing you knew who martin
luther king was you knew who you know
you knew about frederick douglass you
knew about rosa parks you knew mike
ilitch was funding rosa parks his entire
life in uh detroit you know just
it's it's a matter of of course we cared
why would anybody think that we didn't
when did all of a sudden this happen
where we were no that and that's the
issue the right thing it's a trojan
horse where they go no no it's not about
slavery said it wasn't uh you're not
guilted enough because now we need to
make sure that that is copy-pasted
forms of inequity today not an equality
in equity right they've moved those
terms inequity wasn't used as the term
it's now inequity it's no longer about
equality so look let me continue the 40s
with stupid accents
2015 going down this trail the virginia
department of education told schools to
quote embrace critical race theory
that's almost a word for word the
problem that we have with it and quote
to re-engineer attitudes and belief
systems oh uh detroit uh school
superintendent uh nikolai vitti uh had
this
because detroit detroit
if it's detroit schools you know it's
good he had this to say about critical
race theory our curriculum is uh deeply
using critical race theory oops um
especially in social studies well they
find it uh in english language arts and
the other uh disciplines we made
we were very intentional about creating
uh curriculum infusing materials
and embedding critical race here within
now here's the thing i wanna i'm going
to continue going back to this
the english arts he said it's about
particularly injecting race where it
needn't be no one is saying that you
shouldn't teach the discrepancy in race
of course that occurred during the slave
trade right just as we should teach the
the inequity between races with the uh
mediterraneans who were enslaved by the
north africans upward upwards of a
million yeah depending on whether you
look at the estimates and again this is
why i say slavery wasn't really about
race it was about people enslaving other
people because you can find people from
every race enslaving people from every
other race including their own race so
to see it solely through the prism of
race is uh to misinterpret what the
slave trade was not saying like whoopi
did the holocaust was not about race no
they said we're doing this because of
race right slavery they just said we can
enslave well these are the ones who are
being sold and it wasn't exclusive to
one race of people but this is the issue
and they want to gaslight americans
saying you don't want this to be taught
no one is saying that american history
shouldn't be taught it's whether it is
appropriate to inject it into say i
don't know english studies to inject it
into say i don't know math and you can
comment below especially anyone who's
been in public school
in the last 10 years and we have a
i want to know if any of you
either were not taught about slavery or
not taught that slavery is bad or if you
did attend a school where crt was
incorporated i want to know what your
experience was because i have no idea i
don't know what kids do in school do
they still have to buy textbooks so
seattle public schools i'm just going to
rapid fire through this they push
critical race theory as a part of the
racial equity and black studies programs
universities here's something else
universities are actually preparing
teachers on how to teach social justice
to children using
critical race theory scholarships now
let me clear let me make sure that you
understand this you're gonna say well
it's teaching universities no what i'm
saying is they have critical race theory
scholarships
for people who learn how to teach it to
children
that's several layers of systemic
[ __ ]
can i get a pell grant to lie
sure exactly well how good at it are you
wait hold on a second you asian uh no
sure
man i could have got a scholarship for
teaching black culture yeah
exactly he also could have gotten a seat
on the detroit public school board well
there you go is that the guy that cashed
the giant check from ellen and bought
shoes yes
and by the way for a thousand more
examples you can go to chris ruffo's
twitter because john oliver tried to tar
and feather him and uh he of course
provides original sources so we have the
references all available okay here's
another uh point that john oliver makes
he tries to say that chris
ruffo pointing to crt in government is
and this is what john oliver does of
course we know that he cherry picks if
the side accuses you of doing so they're
often accusing you of what they're doing
if it doesn't really make sense he's
accusing
this chris ruffo a man who studies
critical race theory and is critical of
it of cherry-picking but in the wake of
the george floyd protests just as
americans beginning to grapple with
systemic racism fox news began featuring
two billion dollars in damage as part of
their efforts to swing that pendulum
back hard and in one appearance he
pointed to diversity trainings in
government as evidence of crt's
influence and he spoke directly to
president trump through the camera about
what he wanted to see happen and with
that
crt or crucially rufo's definition of it
was suddenly absolutely everywhere fox
news kept pushing it mentioning the term
critical race theory nearly 5 000 times
last year alone and the network zeroed
in on its supposed use in schools with
roofo telling fox's audience that crt
has really become the default ideology
of the public education system yes
absolutely what roofo has been cleverly
doing is cherry picking the worst
examples that he can find of lessons in
classrooms or training materials for
teachers and saying that is
crt
okay
so
we just showed you examples from
well we used his examples to show you
what they believe we've just showed you
examples of what they're teaching in
some schools public school boards and
what they want to teach and now he's
saying that this man is cherry-picking
particularly seems to have
an issue with uh chris ruffo um
i guess misrepresenting right government
affiliate or what actually had
organizations yeah so let's go to one uh
govern government affiliate organization
like lockheed martin's uh they have
white privilege statements that you can
read
i think this is concerning let me read
some quotes i can dismiss another's
voice with little or no consequence when
i'm told about our national heritage i
am shown people of my race made it what
it is this is you know a checklist to
make sure that you uh feel guilty about
any of these statements well i thought
it was like i could kick your ass
privilege like where i just don't care
if you don't like what i say right this
is lockheed martin it's the
government-affiliated organization i
don't think that was white or black or
anything else and they un-ironically use
white privilege look i don't care if
you're left or you're right okay at this
point i think we can can we all find
common ground and agree that if you hear
someone unironically use the term white
privilege in day-to-day life they're an
[ __ ] you don't want to be friends
with yeah 100 agreed yes especially when
they're uh like a karen yes and it's
like you're the embodiment of white
privilege right yeah you don't use it
not only white privilege uh
the only reason i'm not hitting you is
because you're a woman right you're
franzia privilege you just poked your
finger in my chest
i mean i gave you at least one
casablanca i mean just so you know like
it's just but you got a mohawk and you
know you got the law on your side my
point is men treat men very differently
than we do women women benefit from
privilege in many many ways
yeah the non-being how many times have
you with a woman not treated her the
exact way you would treat a man
justifiably justifiably of course under
the eyes of the law right if a man if
one of your friends gets in your face
and shoves you
right what are you going to do it's
going to be good or blows how many times
does that happen to anyone out there
with a woman and you don't do anything
right
i also don't ask a man to bring me a
sandwich well that's true well you
shouldn't at least not if you want a
good sandwich no no but you do it yeah
sometimes
it's a power move john oliver's john
oliver's point there he was basically
saying see he tries to pick the ch
cherry picks the worst examples i'm like
okay so let's just assume that you're
right those are the words this is where
it goes
that's the point john is that the worst
examples are actually being taught right
the worst examples
unlike your worst examples of radical
conservatives saying we don't want the
government co-parenting with us we
should be able to teach our children
right from wrong which by the way i know
is considered a r they consider that a
more radical theory than the idea that
the world is layered entirely through uh
prisms of race right see everything
through the lens of race they think it's
more radical for a parent to say i
should be able to raise my own kid oh
look him up treat them like the truckers
or the cafe owners so he's a witch kid
they were both used and this is by going
to a public school and this is uh paying
attention up to 10th grade right um
both sides were used and when you looked
at it it was black and white especially
when you talked about slavery the
different people that were involved in
it and how they helped each other how
they helped each other out of it the
people that influenced the other people
to change their ways yep look it through
a different spectrum and that's the way
that it was taught it was not taught
that there was a white savior in any way
whatsoever many in many ways it was
taught as a black savior harriet tubman
people like that people that were very
very brave that's what were sought to us
and where we were and what and of course
we knew that there is always going to be
room to grow there's always going to be
things to change but we were always
taught that that that was always taught
as what you know let me ask you
something now is what divides us let me
ask you something okay because yes and i
went to public school as well in canada
though so it's very silly um we're
spending the entire semester on how they
burn down the white house it's just
silly it's like okay you're one win yeah
that wasn't even a win you lost you got
an eight plus overall you're one and 159
you got an a plus in syrup class yes
i know how to tap a tree
so let me ask you this because school is
supposed to equip children
for history only serves a purpose if it
equips you for the world of today right
to learn from history's lessons correct
you don't simply learn history for
history's sake okay so it's meant to
equip you uh for the world of today
hopefully to create better upstanding
citizens who can improve the world and
make them a better place let me ask you
this
were you ever taught about slavery going
on in the world today in school
um
i was somewhat yeah i never was i was
taught
not really but i was taught that it
still existed in the world yeah but do
you think that there are more slaves
right now no today than ever in recorded
history on earth and i'll get to that in
closing did you know that no no no we
just we blank it in terms like uh human
trafficking yeah we give it that's
slavery let me ask you i had to when you
talk about schools public schools being
propaganda arms of a bastion of
right-wing extremism i had to unlearn
things that i learned in school like my
god there was a native american genocide
i didn't realize that we have more
people who are 1 16th cherokee or apache
algonquin than ever before because they
were encouraged to intermarry i didn't
learn that i learned that we gave them
smallpox blankets and took them out with
diseases sent with year i think over a
century before germ theory i learned in
school of this wonderful horse culture
right horseback culture with native
americans i didn't know that they hadn't
domesticated horses i never learned any
of those things i had to learn these
things after i didn't learn in school
that abraham lincoln was a republican
did you
i also like when you know anybody who's
white says they're 118th cherokee
because then i know not to talk to them
anymore especially if they co-author
pow-wow yeah i'm like that's really
interesting
and cheekbones so here's the thing no
but sex slavery of all things too should
be taught in school yes because it's a
danger today yes and when you're when
you're taught when you're young it's
just you can be kidding after this and
that whatever they obviously can't get
into it with certain children i
understand that right but if you're
talking about teens and you're talking
about sex education which i believe that
should be taught i certainly think that
human trafficking should be a part of
that you're talking about the most
vulnerable age of the most vulnerable
people on the planet i mean other than
babies and everything but you're talking
about easily manipulated people here's
the thing i will tell you this you've
just sort of bought into
a lot of people here human trafficking
yeah and they equate it with sex slavery
there is human trafficking actually it's
for work
yeah most human trafficking is not sex
slavery so that's where they go oh human
trafficking and people think oh it's a
pimp it's like the deuce no no no more
slaves right now
than ever in the world and i know
adjusted for population maybe it's a
lower percentage but i'll get to the
numbers they might shock you wish i
would have learned this in school so
kids should be learning about these
sensitive issues
from parents that's what i think
certainly issues as far as well you know
the term nuance we should learn about
slavery yeah we should learn that
slavery was bad we should also learn
that slavery still goes on however john
oliver believes that your children and
you can watch it you can watch it get
more drastic and i encourage you to go
watch the full clip
should learn all of it including the
opinions taught as fact from schools not
their parents educators are working very
hard to find age-appropriate ways to
talk about race and racism in the
classroom and if you do it right you
don't stop at the civil rights movement
you tell the story all the way to the
present day which kids want and need
they have questions about what they can
see with their own eyes and they deserve
good answers and it is frankly far
better for them to have these
discussions in a supportive educational
environment how do you answer the
potential
neighborhood screaming match at
thanksgiving but the panic over crt
threatens to shut those conversations
wrong he just has the wrong answer it is
likely to do well look let me get so
he's making
this
satirical arter in the san francisco
chronicle look a lot less ethical so the
left's introduction of anti-racism and
gender identity in schools face a bitter
backlash from parents
ending parenthood would end the backlash
helping dismantle white supremacy and
outdated gender norms my proposal would
merely make mandatory handovers of
babies to the state now this is meant to
be uh satirical but that's not what he's
saying look what do you think is going
to happen he's just assuming that he has
the right answer yeah especially if
anything right now who's been most
negatively impacted
by and you said this the lockdowns by
the protests the riots
people in those communities
so what should be the answer from a
teacher if they go why did my dad's
business get burned down by the way if
they're fortunate enough to have a
father and that's a big because
statistically that matters hey there's
another question why don't i have a dad
yeah what's the answer john oliver could
it be well you know what because of the
model cities program because of the
modern welfare state because of uh if
you look at lyndon johnson and what this
is why we actually encourage single
parent households or well you know what
that was your father's franchise the
walgreens was burned down because of
people who were looking an excuse to
commit violence and your father
committed no wrong and you know what
this is the pro no the answer is going
to be uh uh uh systemic racism and that
is taught to your kids and parents right
now are saying we don't want that taught
to our kids not that the slave trade
existed right yeah and the questions
that will come up that i'm sure they're
going to answer correctly too or why did
that police officer shoot that girl with
a knife well because she was going to
stab somebody else so i saved her life
right that won't ever come up who is she
going to stab uh black girl right no no
no racist cop hey why was jacob blake uh
shot
i bet you would be hard-pressed to find
a single teacher
let's say
the eastern seaboard
i'm being somewhat facetious but not
really statistically less than one
percent you know like a heterosexual
male chance of getting in north america
you're more right than you want to be
there are a few stragglers but it's
statistically less than one percent yeah
i bet you would find less than one
percent of teachers on the eastern
seaboard addressing high school students
when teaching the jacob blake situation
saying well actually what happened was
uh he was trying to kidnap his own
children from the woman he had sexually
assaulted who called the cops to enforce
the restraining order then reach for a
knife under the floorboard of his car to
try and stab cops before they shot him i
don't think you'll find a single teacher
teaching that i guarantee you you'll
find at least half saying that
there's systemic racism from police
shooting black men so my point is
it's not that it's not leftist do we
really think that public school teachers
are mostly conservative for crying out
it's that it's not liberal
enough let's just move that over when
bringing of lyndon b johnson everything
else it is systemic you're just not
explaining what that means at all
exactly that's the problem it's the
exact same answer without any
explanation right it's just white people
bad and by the way let's make sure that
some kids in this class feel shame for
something that is uh no fault of their
exactly so what is systemic racism oh
it's not important but gofundme bought
the guy a nice wheelchair yes yeah
exactly also they bought some nice k
bars for the other catch and release
felons over there in new york so we're
really proud about that we have a
revolving door literally you don't even
have to post bail yeah by the way freeze
the trucker funds please okay sorry i
have to go back to curriculum now
the anti-critical race theory movement
this is what john oliver wants to do
it's nothing but straw man straw man
straw man straw man strong instrument i
would love if he provided his references
publicly but he doesn't none of these
shows do because they don't want a light
it burns
um
he wants you to believe that the
anti-critical race theory movement is
being driven
exclusively by
white parents even a manufactured panic
is a panic
those parents at school board meetings
are just a riot angry and as any little
league coach knows
once you reach a critical mass of angry
white parents
there will be consequences
okay so here's the thing 45 it's true 45
of whites in america think that critical
race three will make race relations
worse yeah okay
do you know what percentage of all other
minorities think it will make race
relations worse
exactly 45 really yeah exactly 45
weird it's like we're the same it's
almost like we're the same now to be
fair only 32 percent of blacks think it
will make it worse but the point is when
you include all the minorities because
you know i think it matters it can't oh
no wait it's just depending on the day
right is it oh anti-race anti-asian hate
crimes until okay then it's it's it's
the oppression olympics right okay and
it's only the black only the black
statistic matters it's still a lot a
third of black people think this and
what are they the the black face of
white supremacy john oliver yes it's
just a white parent problem yes and uh
that's the empirical from rasmussen
here's the anecdotal just so you can see
it for yourself see i don't want to do
that john oliver works just anecdotal
right that's why i try to show you the
empirical but i also think it's nice to
see by the way i think hey thanks for
laying in the control room he
exclusively pulled clips of good-looking
black men like we don't know what he's
up to
have you tried talking down to your
audience
yes he's pretty good at it now um these
parents are definitely not just white
but we're taking the wheel back from
washington all the way to raleigh and
into our local school board and from
jesus because crt
all of that
the parents don't want it it's a big fat
lie there's not one if they're if you
believe in ceo i'm looking dude i'll
tell you you're a liar because that
means you look at your black
and you look at your white neighbor and
say that they're evil regardless of the
experience that you've had with them
and we're not going to do that
how did that get worse
it's some white man kept me down how am
i now directing over folks that look
just like you not many white men
physically could wha what kept me down
what oppressed me
specimen off the streets to where i am
right now you gonna sit here and tell me
this lie a critical race theory of this
this the reason why black folks can't
get ahead because of white folks are you
kidding me
this is what we come to now i can't
believe we even talked about this right
now we can do all of this because we
live in an incredible country
america that offers us limitless
possibilities for all people who are
willing to dream and work hard
that is why i love this country and that
is why i oppose
critical race theory
and anything that resembles it ah he
won't be shown in the media i should
have tried some shitty slam poetry
so
last week also san francisco voters led
by asian americans you know the ones who
were being pushed on subway tracks who
we cared about four weeks ago until they
were no longer convenient correct uh
they voted to recall three school board
members
who abolished merit-based admissions
yeah
now why do they abolish merit-based
admissions look
okay just go to the reference i think
you can guess
so here's another claim that john oliver
makes that critical race theory is not
uh actually like a revolutionary program
that would do away
with uh our societal foundations and by
the way this is something also that's
pretty pretty important
conservatives people on the right okay
we're concerned with the destruction of
not institutions like
reliable sources with brian stelter uh
not nancy pelosi's house right this is
what they say they're like oh they're
trying to know that guy's 36 i'm sorry
to interrupt i found that out yesterday
what a nightmare what he's 36 36 brian
seltzer oh my word right
not enough podlings in the world i think
it's why i didn't sleep
[Laughter]
so this dude's younger than me would it
was a tragedy well
i'm sorry i mean to cut you we all have
our black we all have our black stains
in history i mean just slavery
the railroads internment camps
he's delter god doesn't like you no
um
i think this is important to notice
conservatives are actually concerned
with doing away with the foundations of
our country of what created this country
so i mean namely this is why you see and
you see this is very different right you
see the left they talk about things like
well okay
there's mistrust in our institutions
well hold on you don't really trust the
institutions because you want to add
seats to the supreme court right well
there's showing mistrust institutions
yeah but you guys want to do away with
the filibuster they're sewing with
stressor institutions yeah but you
actually want the government to be able
to censor other platforms and which
speech is elect so really yeah what
you're complaining about is americans
sowing mr and by by sowing mistrust what
you mean is not trusting media not
trusting their house of representatives
not trusting this current former vice
president you say that's a problem
because these institutions that
currently exist are what make america
america okay now you have people on i'm
doing it for you you're right my left
but you have people on the right and
what they have a problem with
is sowing distrust and sowing uh
creating cracks in the institutions that
made our country what it is not current
media not current supreme court not
current person in office but our
founding documents the constitution the
declaration of independence the
foundations the principles that made
this country not only what it was but
also ultimately led to the quickest
abolishment of slavery
that is it's unprecedented leaving a
world superpower one century to become
the only world superpower the next while
ending
a centuries millennia-long practice at
least in this portion of the world it
still exists across the globe which
we'll get to so john oliver tells you
that uh
this is conservatives are just concerned
that crt is a revolutionary program that
might overturn constitutional principles
wouldn't that be silly here's his
argument but critics of it argue that
the ideas behind crt are being taught in
schools and often present a
hyperbolically distorted version of what
those ideas are and a key person here is
this man a conservative activist named
christopher ruffo he claims crt is
actually a revolutionary program that
would overturn the principles of the
declaration and destroy the remaining
structure of the constitution which it
just isn't it isn't
that i don't really like to hear about
what we should do with our constitution
from a guy who comes from a country that
was so shitty we left and drafted it
so true
crt critical race theorem using the
abbreviation yeah yeah it's fine
uh kids like that kirchhoff
what did oj have crt here's the
definition
of crt from who from who from who from
the founders of the feast it is
antithetical to the united states of
america the two cannot coexist just like
by the way that bumper sticker you know
a lot of those little symbols can't
co-exist because the c wants to eat all
the other letters so this is the
definition of crt about my car from the
founders they wrote critical race theory
questions the very foundations
of the liberal order including equality
theory legal reasoning enlightenment
rationalism and neutral principles of
constitutional law i think we even have
a clip
discussing race in a classroom is easy
or even always done well experts in this
field will readily admit that oh sorry
you know what i was expecting a
different clip but uh we'll pull that
later we'll get it up on my clip um
play that clip again i think people
might have missed it i want i want
people to listen to that clip again
discussing race in a classroom is easy
or even always done well experts in this
field will readily admit that okay so
this is how he tries to frame him he
says right i'm not saying it's going to
be easy i'm not saying that
that's not the problem
that's not the problem that people
like my people in this room have with
critical race theory it's not that we
think oh no it should be easy to teach
histories no none of us are saying it
should be easy to teach the history of
slavery none of us are saying that
should be an easy conversation to teach
the history of the holocaust for crying
out loud goldberg needs remedial
but
what we're saying is
not whether it will be uh comfortable
whether it's appropriate
that's the problem that americans have
and by the way americans of all colors
have with critical race theory they have
a problem with race being injected into
math
into science into english as you just
heard from that language the con the
question here isn't whether discussing
race
will be easier whether it be through crt
black liberation theology the question
that matters is when is it appropriate
is it appropriate at all and is it
accurate and by the way while we're
talking about this and the gross
misrepresentation of people who are
opposed critical race three namely by
the way parents that's also very telling
when you look at who the left opposes
truckers working class people the people
who oppose critical race theory if you
look at the demographics mostly parents
screw them right we want the single
white females with the mohawk we want
them to be in charge of what our
government does because it's worked so
well for us recently as we've been just
not even slowly now we're racing down
the path to serfdom so um you know what
let me tell you this how about this i'm
fine i'm fine with teaching critical
race theory
under condition this is a deal that i
would take tomorrow
so that was a leading question i asked
you earlier dave because yes
i will find you know what okay we can
teach critical race theory in schools
if
if
it has there has to be a 50 50
percentage at least so equal time given
to the fact that there are more slaves
today on earth than ever in recorded
history where do i get that well that's
a 40 million number right now worldwide
if you look at the 15th to 19th century
13 million total now i know you're
saying adjusted for population doesn't
matter that should still be a shocking
number and unlike slavery in the past
it's something that we can
we can change today
we can change today hey do all
minorities matter
this is why when people say oh all lives
matter that's uh that's racist hold on a
second 40 million slaves today
and by the way you have to teach where
that takes place today doesn't take
place in the united states almost
entirely where africa
asia
and the middle east
and by the way that number is probably
probably an undercount because there are
things like indentured servitude well
what's that indentured servitude slavery
well it's basically you have to work off
a debt and then you well you know you
won't be paid and then you you won't
have to work for me anymore oh when's
the debt paid off i'll just keep
extending the debt never yeah that's how
some of the most beautiful structures in
these modern these modern blazing
saddles
like dubai abu dhabi indentured servants
qatar where clock boy went
sex slavery is going on today across the
country this is
it's going on in this country by the way
sex slavery in this country not by the
government but it actually is going on
across the globe in some cases
sanctioned by governments so why why if
our goal is to improve i thought the
goal to education was to make the world
a better place
well there are 40 million people right
now who could use some [ __ ] help and
you want to say what you want to talk
about let me tell you a little story
about reparations okay i've got a friend
i hope she doesn't mind me telling the
story this uh this girl
grandmother was from poland
and by the way what we're talking about
reparations we're talking about right
reparations we've sort of seen a little
bit of that haven't we in the pandemic
where we've had checks to everybody
right everybody got a check i'm not
saying it's a racing but everybody got a
check right at this point of course we
had uh the moratorium rent we had catch
and release you could steal what you
wanted as long as it was under 999
dollars how's that been working out when
you give people free stuff does that
make a society better so i'm just saying
take that amplify it you got reparations
but while we're talking about
reparations because you're so
obtuse that you see it exclusively
through the prism of race okay i've got
a friend her grandmother from poland
uh was in poland during world war ii
nazi occupied germany
they came in
and uh they sifted through the people
and turns out that she was aryan enough
lucky her so she became one of the ss's
breeding [ __ ]
to perpetuate the aryan race
and then fled later to america there's
more to the story i can probably let
this person tell it sometime
is there anything you can think of more
terrifying imagine when we're talking
slavery's horrible
but this is a person who wasn't
quick a good grandfather wasn't or
correct richter craig your grandmother
didn't have someone come into their town
and forcibly rape them to carry aryan
children
this happened in her lifetime
and then she fled to america
does her daughter get to go back say hey
germany you owe me reparations why
aren't we talking about that if we're
talking about reparations there's
certainly a lot that we could [ __ ]
about in recent history hey not only
that there's certainly a lot that we
could [ __ ] about today but you know
what instead of how about how about this
instead of just bitching about things
that happened that we all agree were
wrong and none of your solutions would
do anything
how about we focus on issues that we can
do something about today 40 million
slaves today
40 million slaves you're gonna wait for
you're gonna wait for the celebrities to
do your job for you to start some
charity
the job of schooling is to equip people
in this country to make the world a
better place you think you're making the
world a better place by putting them
through the public schooling system then
offering them a critical race theory
scholarship so they can go back and tell
white kids what a piece of [ __ ] they are
no we can teach critical race theory if
if it's taught alongside more slaves
than ever in recorded history today 50
50 equal time youtube you have to piss
off that is a deal i would take tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
bye